[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants au sort aux formes
j'espère que ce soir nicolas et
pimprenelle ne te feront pas des blagues
mon cher nounours si jamais ils m'ont
faut une rare à eux je sais me défendre
moi j'ai l'impression qu'ils seront sage
je n'entends aucun bruit ne nous
énervons pas mon échelle
hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis
bonsoir au petit dico l'en but pas
preneur pas les parties tchesnokov est
parti boucher mais boudons pas dans le
ciel mon gros nounours
elle a dit je vais prendre une échelle
je vais chercher north blacks
[Musique]
mademoiselle pas trop belle sortie de
votre cachette et non je n'ai pas sous
le lit allons voir à la cuisine mais je
te dis qu'elle est allée chercher
mais non elle n'est pas dans la cuisine
elle se cache sûrement dans la salle de
bain
tu t'entraînes ya toi elle n'est pas
dans la salle
mais elle n'est pas la maison
bien sûr que non puisque lé parti de
chercher voyant nicolas c'est grave
une petite fille ne sort pas tout seul
la nuit il fait froid n'a pas peur
[Musique]
allons allons du sang froid et de
l'énergie l'ours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'étoile 00 00
palau allons patron c'est vous ici nous
nours nous cherchons pas prône elle vous
ne l'avez pas vu elle n'est pas avec
vous sur le nuage
nos routes
merci à tous ceux petits preneur ou
peut-être bientôt quelle petite coquille
combine
je me fais un ses soucis moi si ça
continue je vais tomber malade
or d'auto me faire ça à bois
[Musique]
prenez mon petit lapin la grosse bagarre
viennent annonce va bien le but du corps
ne ment il ment encore fait mais
maintenant aller vite au lit sinon c'est
moi qui vous attrape et vous allez voir
ce que vous allez voir
jean bleu ta jambe le tas en écossais
n'en finit pas perdre alors donc mes
huit petits garnements
[Musique]
vous avez fait de ces frais nov
c'est un berniche h et emmène la vieille
bonne nicolas aubin saint louis l'homme
n'est pas bonne elle
[Musique]
connus des enfants en temps mais vous
sagement embrasser bien fort aux parents
et faites de beaux rêves à te voilà mon
pauvre nounours patron moquant feu
blague mais tu adores sa monde on ne
nous soit dupe au patron ce lot dur jute
reprend tout est bien qui finit bien
allons en route fidèle compagnon et le
gros nigo bonne nuit à demain
bordeaux dit
[Musique]
oh